BRAHIM ELBOUCHIKHI: Good
afternoon, everybody.
My name is Brahim Elbouchikhi.
I'm a product manager
on the Daydream team,
and I'm responsible
for Play Store VR.
I've been pretty fortunate to
work on ecosystem formation
for the past five years.
Before this, I
was on Google Play
for four years, where I
led monetization, search,
and discovery.
And I don't know how
many of you remember
Android Market, and then
within Android market,
the 10B sale, which is when
we turned all the apps to be
10 cents and then we had a
sale, and all this good stuff.
And I don't know if you
remember-- the store fell over
within like two
hours of the sale
because we couldn't
handle the traffic.
And that was a really bad
day for me and my team.
Now, we've come a long
way from there, right?
So Google Play is a much
more stable platform.
We've got payments
all over the world,
we've got users
spending billions
of dollars buying your content.
We've come a long way,
and what attracted
me to come into VR and
Daydream is the opportunities
to work with you again to figure
out some similar questions,
but in an entirely
different context.
If you think of back
then, we were thinking
of how will I monetize my app?
How will I keep my users around?
How do I do a user acquisition?
What content would
actually stick?
And those questions are
very much open today in VR.
They are an entirely
open field for us
as a group to figure
out, and to build
those big brands in VR and on
Daydream as we have on mobile.
So the hope is that
if in five years,
we're collectively working on
another frontier technology,
that we can look back
and then say again
that we've created value,
that we went past the hype
and actually delivered
real value for users,
and built a multibillion
dollar business on Daydream.
That's the goal.
That's why we had
this session today.
And I can't wait to kind of
get started and kind of start
working with you on this.
So a recap of Daydream, right?
So you've heard this from
Clay at the first keynote
this morning.
Daydream is just
incredibly exciting for us
to start to tell you
the story of Daydream.
I have been working on
it for quite some time,
and the team has been incredibly
thoughtful about thinking
about the various aspects
that create a high quality VR
experience.
So we've got the
smartphone, which
is at the core of the
experience, obviously.
We've got a headset
that's comfortable,
we've got a controller
that can allow
you to create really immersive
and awesome experiences,
and then you've got
the apps, which is
what we're here to talk about.
That's where we fit
in in this talk.
Now, just before we
get started, it's
important to step back and
talk about Google Play.
I mentioned it's
a stable platform,
and Daydream is essentially
built on top of Google Play.
Right?
It's our distribution platform.
We, in a way, get
it for free, which
is an amazing asset to have.
We got ahead 190 countries
where you distribute
free apps, 130 countries
where you can sell your apps,
and we've got the one
billion 30-day active users
that Google Play has.
Now, before anybody
yells it out,
those are not VR users today.
I'm not trying to
make that claim.
What I am going to say is
that at Daydream, we're
trying to operate
at Android scale.
That our intention is to
operate at Android scale,
meaning hundreds of millions of
users using Daydream devices.
And the way we get there is
through the typical smartphone
evolution where today's
premium devices,
the ones that can
run VR experiences,
are next year's mid-range,
and the following year's
potentially even
low end devices.
So if you take
that evolution, you
can see that in a
couple years, we
will have hundreds
of millions of users
on Daydream-ready
devices that are
ready to consume the mobile
VR experiences that you all
are going to build.
But the main point
is the intention
is to operate at
Android scale, to have
an ecosystem of devices,
of content creators,
and of partners creating
headsets and controllers.
All right.
So with that in mind,
I remember back then,
I used to meet a lot of
developers for mobile
and we used to have a
lot of conversations
around monetization,
discovery, et cetera.
And in this talk,
we tried to try
to get ahead of some of those
questions that you have.
We tried to pull user
studies that we've
had with some fairly large
numbers of users of mobile VR
and distill those into insights
that can be useful to you
at this stage of
your app development.
We've also looked at
data that we have,
and we've talked to many
of you, and we've also
talked honestly
amongst ourselves
and debated for a long,
long time to say, OK.
Based on our
expertise, we've got
people coming from console
world, people coming
from mobile, people
coming from all sorts
of different
backgrounds thinking
about how is VR potentially
going to evolve from here.
Nobody knows the answers
to a lot of these things,
but we hope that these
insights can at least help
get the conversation
going and help us thinking
about the right set of things.
All right.
So with that, I'm going
to jump in and talk
about the first insight.
OK.
So with mobile, you're
generally dealing
with a fairly distracted user.
They are at a bus station.
They are waiting for a
friend and killing some time.
They're interacting with your
app multiple times a day,
but fairly in short
interactions, a couple minutes.
Right?
And because of that,
mobile has evolved
into free-to-play mechanics,
and all sorts of things
that kind of have derived
from that user behavior.
That's great.
When you think of
mobile VR, it's
an entirely different setting.
Our studies showed that
users are spending 30 minutes
plus in each session,
that they're also
having a single session a day,
not multiple sessions a day,
that they're doing this at home.
No one is wearing these
headsets in the streets.
Just FYI.
Right?
Nobody is.
Probably nobody will.
It's at home, long sessions.
Actually, we've
had photos of users
that kind of like lean
back, kind of like they're
watching TV.
That's the state of
mind of the user.
They're waiting to be, in
a way, kind of immersed
to be drawn into really
rich content that
has a lot of narrative, and
they're in that state of mind.
And so as you build
your apps, the way
we try to synthesize
this is to say,
think a sit down
meal, not a snack.
And sit down meals come
with certain expectations
of duration, of deliciousness
of the food, and also of cost.
So when you design
your app, while we
think of mobile as
a snack, mobile VR
is more of a sit down meal.
Just as a thing.
All right.
So the second insight.
This is an old chart.
I used this chart
for a couple of years
now to demonstrate the
importance of quality
to monetization.
And it's totally
intuitive, right?
If you build higher
quality content,
you will have more monetization.
You will make more.
People will pay more for that.
Nothing surprising here.
The scale is a bit surprising.
And in VR, we all know
that quality's going
to be even more important.
Right?
It's an order of magnitude,
probably, more important,
because you can literally
make people feel bad,
like physically sick.
So Alice is going to dive
into this much more later,
so what I want to talk about,
however, is first impressions.
So as an industry, we're
in those early days, right?
And we have a ton of first
time users coming through.
And each time a first time user
experiences one of your apps,
there are two ways
it can happen.
Two things that can happen.
They can either become an
advocate for the industry,
and spread the industry and
the fact that it's awesome,
and tell their friends and
family that, hey, VR is here.
It's real.
It's awesome.
Or, they can either
confirm their skepticism
or become a skeptic by
saying it's not ready,
and potentially walking
away from VR for years.
For us as an industry,
not just for that one app.
And so the insight is,
as you design your apps,
think of that.
Think of the fact that
many of our users,
as we move into the mainstream,
are first time users.
Meaning that the experience
needs to hand-hold them
through what VR is, to
not like immediately
drop them in the deep
end of a VR experience,
to make sure you introduce
them to these things,
to the mechanics,
to the experience.
Be thoughtful about it, and
know that we're collectively
responsible for the
success of the industry.
Right?
If these things don't
catch, if the word of mouth
doesn't allow people
to get excited,
the people don't
speak well of VR,
we won't have a
successful industry.
So that's the second
thing I wanted to share.
The third thing
is about novelty.
And VR is incredibly
novel right now.
Right?
I mean, one of the most
fun things you can do in VR
is show VR to people who've
never seen it before.
Right?
I mean, literally, demoing
VR is one of the most
fun you can do in VR.
And it's really easy
and somewhat tempting
to just say, oh, I'm going to
drop someone somewhere amazing
and be like, that's awesome.
That's a great experience.
That is a great
experience for 30 seconds.
And then as soon as
you achieve presence
and you achieve like, oh my god,
I'm in space, you're like, OK.
What can I do?
You look around again and you're
like, oh, can I touch anything?
No.
And users don't engage further.
Users will not pay for novelty.
Users pay for
engaging experiences.
And so when we designed
the Daydream controller,
we had this
specifically in mind.
We wanted to give you
a tool that you can
use to create engaging content.
So if you're going
to drop me in space,
make sure I can point at any
planet and learn about it.
Or maybe I can grab a planet
and toss it out of the galaxy.
Help me do something there and
go beyond the novelty of VR,
because that's the easy
path is to use the novelty.
The fourth insight.
Ah.
Oh.
I went too far.
OK, so the fourth insight is
about-- I learned this actually
when I was in mobile,
and on the Play Store,
we used to get a
lot of people that
run these queries like a
search query that says game.
App.
That's it.
And we struggle with what--
that's there-- there's
very little intent there.
There's very little we can do
to help the user in the search
results, because
it's so high level.
And we've learned
that that's basically
new users who don't understand
what their device is
capable of, or new
users who don't
know how to search for things.
What are the words I need
to put to actually search
for the right content?
And the insight
here is, I believe
that the entire industry
in VR is in that stage,
that we all-- there's no
evolved, clear taxonomy of how
we describe these
experiences and these apps.
We don't have clear
expectations of what
actually can be achieved in VR.
For example, a
teleportation app.
Is that a travel app?
It could be, but I doubt anybody
will search for travel app
when they want to find
a teleportation app.
So because of that, what
you need to think of
is that users are in their
window shopping mode,
not in a grocery shopping mode.
And what that means is,
we've gotten used in mobile
now where users come with
a specific thing they're
looking for.
They go and they
type specifically
what they're looking for.
Most users are at
that stage now,
because they're familiar with
what a smartphone can do.
But in VR, a lot of
users are going to come
and they're going to wait
to be dazzled by the app.
What is this about?
What can it do?
So as you design, whether in
the store, in the Play Store,
or out on the web, or
your YouTube trailers,
your 360 trailers for your
app-- whatever you do,
make sure you realize that
the users' state of mind when
they are looking for
apps at this point in VR
is very undefined.
It's very high level.
They're kind of more on the
receiving end, browsing, window
shopping.
They don't know
something specific.
They're not looking
for something specific.
So that's another one.
The fifth insight is that VR
is meant to be experienced.
And I'm going to unpack
it for you a bit.
A lot of technologies,
it's really easy
to describe them in words.
So for example, if you go
to describe 3D printing
to someone, you could
just say, well, you know,
this thing was made,
probably in China,
and then it got
shipped to your house.
Instead of that, you can have a
CAD model and you can hit Print
and it just shows
up at your home.
Right on the printer.
Right?
And the people kind of
get what it's about.
Now, when you try to
describe VR to someone,
you tell them, well, you
feel like you're there.
And they kind of look at
you and they're like, well,
but I'm not there.
But then you say, well,
no, but then, you know,
you're-- we have two different
images in your eyes, we have--
we introduce parallax,
as so you can see depth.
And then you have head tracking,
and motion and photo on just
for fun.
And you talk about all
these things and the user,
they don't really get
it, most of the time.
And so what you need is you need
someone to experience your app.
They need to actually be in it
to understand what it's about.
And this doesn't go away.
This actually stays for
every single experience
that I'm going to try to engage
with, or buy, or install.
I'm going to want to
experience it before I do that.
So the insight here is,
make sure you give users
ways to try and
experience your app
before they have to
increase their commitment.
So if it's basically
a large install,
if I have to download
500 megs Before I even
know what your thing is
about, I'm not going to do it.
If potentially I
need to pay upfront
without even seeing a 360
YouTube trailer about your app,
I may not do it.
So think about ways that
you can introduce the user
to what your experience
is about before asking
them to take that next step.
Our final insight here is
about purchasing and purchasing
behavior.
If you look back at
everything we just
talked about now,
the fact that you
have a single session a day, the
fact that you have a user who's
immersed-- meaning that
purchasing is going to probably
break that immersion.
It's going to get in the way.
If you think about a
lot of these things that
make VR so awesome,
you're not going
to want to have things like
free-to-play mechanics, energy
mechanics, time-based mechanics.
It's just not going to
work, in all likelihood.
Things may change.
But it's going to be hard.
And so what we're recommending
is an experience where
a user is able to
unlock the entire thing
with a single purchase, and that
purchase can be an in-app where
basically, I try
a couple levels,
I get what your app is
about, I experience it,
and then I make a
purchase to unlock
the remainder of the app.
That balances out both the I
need to try it before I buy,
but it also does not disrupt the
experience on a regular basis.
It doesn't try that recurring
monetization loop that's
become so familiar in mobile.
OK.
So to summarize, we would
like you to build high quality
content that has
narrative, that's
equivalent to a beautiful,
awesome book that draws you in
and that you can't put down.
We want you to engage
with users beyond novelty,
because no one pays for novelty.
If you find someone,
let me know.
Let users try your
experience before they
need to take that next
step of commitment.
And finally, think of
ways to allow a user
to make a single purchase to
unlock an entire experience.
Keeping in mind that free to
play may be challenged in VR.
OK.
So with that, I want to move on
to the next part of this talk,
which is Play Store in VR.
You've seen some of
these bits and pieces
through the keynotes
and the videos
and all that sort
of stuff, so I'm
going to go through
them fairly quickly.
This is what we
call Daydream Home.
When the user boots into
VR, they're automatically
dropped into this environment.
The one thing I want to
highlight here is the icon.
People are familiar
with the Play Store.
This is the same place
I get my 2D apps,
it's the same place that
I make my purchases,
and it's the same place I'm
going to do it here in VR.
Now, I don't know
if we'll launch
with this background
in particular,
but I got to tell you that
the team is thinking really
about fun spaces
that are unusual,
that are representative
of the immersion of VR,
that just create a really
nice feel and really fun feel.
So they explain a
lot of those things.
And of course, 2D
does it no justice
in terms of when you see a 2D
screen shot of a VR experience,
again, going back to
the earlier point.
So what you notice here is
content is front and center.
Right?
This is our featured
port in the store,
and you have that
beautiful poster
that has depth, that allows
somebody to kind of get
into what is this about,
as much as we can, at least
at this stage.
You also see the
store representing
what I talked about in terms
of the lack of categories
or taxonomy.
At launch, it's going
to be pretty simple.
You're not going to see tons
of categories, different words
being thrown around.
It's going to be simple, and
we need to keep it simple.
At the bottom, we
have four sections.
The Featured section,
which is curated.
You've got the
Popular section, which
is top charts, essentially,
and then you have two homes
for apps and for games.
As we learn more about what
sort of content types--
and Alice is going to
talk more about that--
are going to emerge, we
will have the store evolve,
but to start with, we're
starting and keeping it simple.
Next is Popular, right?
So even here, we're given a lot
more space for a single item.
It's not so much
of the compressed,
let's have a whole chart
stacked up together
so we can fit as many things
as we can on the screen.
Here, even though
we have more space,
we're actually showing
fewer things at a time.
Because again, that window
shopping experience.
We want someone to be able to
understand what your app is
about one at a time and
just really kind of get
to the next level of commitment,
hopefully, making a purchase
or installing the app.
Lindsay this morning
also showed us
this, which is the Details page.
And the thing I want
to highlight here
is the photosphere, that 360
degree stereoscopic image.
We're doing this,
again, to try to help
with the trying the experience.
I don't think this is
necessarily like entirely
trying it, but it gets us
one step closer to the user
being able to look around
and see what this is about.
Having tried this, it really
is effective in making
sure you understand what
this app is about as a user.
So we're doing
this and every app
will need to submit this
particular photosphere.
Finally, we will support
in-app purchases,
and they will work exactly as
you would expect them to work.
All right.
So Cardboard apps were
about fun, snackable,
short experiences, largely
non-interactive, right?
The one button, they
were kept very simple.
Daydream apps are
quite the opposite.
They're about immersive content,
long form, highly interactive.
The Daydream controller
is key to the last bit.
And the best metaphor
that I can think
of for it is a book that
is incredibly awesome that
draws you in, and
that you get lost in.
It's happened to
every one of us,
where there's some book
you just can't put down.
That's our ideal Daydream app.
And this is a side
thing I was thinking
about when I was rehearsing.
The fact that a book
made out of paper
can do that your
brain and can actually
get you to imagine
things and picture them
in your mind as
clear as if you're
looking at them-- the
fact that a book on paper
can do that is
absolutely ridiculous.
It's absolutely amazing, right?
So if you combine that with
a medium that literally
is meant to make you immersed,
and to actually visualize
all these things--
if you combine
that kind of powerful
narrative with VR as a medium,
it's absolutely amazing
what can be created,
and that's what keeps us really
excited about the potential
of this space.
So with that in
mind, we have a bunch
of talks today and
tomorrow that are
going to try to show you
how to build for Daydream.
In fact, we've learned
there was the prototyping
talk this morning,
Daydream controller talk
next, there is tomorrow's
Designing for Daydream,
there is the high performance
app development tomorrow
as well.
So all those talks
are going to tell you
how to build a Daydream app, or
at least some insights into it.
I'm going to talk about
the boring part, which
is how do you get your app to
be technically a Daydream app.
Like how do we change
the manifest to actually
make it a Daydream app.
So this is a manifest.
A truncated, Android
app manifest.
And it's for a Daydream app.
Now, what I'm
going to do is, I'm
going to walk through
a few of these things
and highlight some
bits and pieces.
These two feature
tags tell Android
that you're using both
the software and hardware
features of Daydream.
This particular thing, this
tag in your activity block
tells the system that you want
to launch directly into VR,
because you don't want
any sort of race condition
or any kind of
transition from 2D to VR.
And so because of that, you
put this in your activity block
to tell Android that I
am an entirely VR app.
I'm only useful in VR, so
trigger me into VR directly.
This is how you specify the two
icon assets I've showed you.
Alex is going to show you a
nice visualization of them,
but basically, in the manifest,
you set these two icons
and you upload the
360 degree image.
Now I'm going to introduce this
concept of a self-contained VR
environment.
And we couldn't come
up with a shorter name.
If you have ideas, let me
know, but basically, it's
something where you can
navigate the entire experience
without running into 2D flows.
If there are 2D flows, you want
them to be graciously handled,
meaning that the user
is told that they need
to take their phone
off for some reason,
and it needs to be
an exceptional thing.
It can be a regular
part of use of the app.
And so the key here, this
is the manifest entry
to tell us what that intent is.
This is the Daydream intent,
and it's a new intent filter
category.
So with that, you
have a Daydream app.
You have an app that's
built from the ground up
to be for Daydream.
It's immersive, it's long
form, it's interactive,
it takes advantage of
the hardware and software
features of the platform.
It is awesome.
It's that beautiful book
that we talked about.
But there is more, right?
After all, this is Android.
And Android yesterday announced
that they've had 65 billion
downloads in 12 months, which
is ridiculous if you think of it
in the context of
the $0.10 promo,
where we had all time 10 billion
at a time and were super happy.
This is 65 billion in 12 months.
And we know that many of
you have users on Android.
You have millions, tens of
millions, hundreds of millions
of users already using
your apps on Android.
So its important for us
to allow you to introduce
Daydream experiences
to your existing apps.
And so we have a
concept of a hybrid app,
and its going to show up.
A hybrid app is an app that has
both 2D flows and a Daydream
experience.
Now, the Daydream
experience comes to life
on a Daydream-ready device.
The 2D flows are
available on every device.
The Play Movie's
team, for example,
when they considered building
a Daydream experience,
they have decided to add it to
their existing Play Movies app.
This does some
really awesome stuff.
Because what this does is it
aligns your development costs,
and it aligns your
user acquisition costs,
and finally, it
allows you to take
advantage of this
large user base
you already have on Android.
So this is super critical.
And the way you do it
is incredibly easy.
You just turn that flag--
the Android Required False--
you turn it from true to false.
And that tells the system
that this app takes advantage
of Daydream when available.
But if not it, can
operate as a 2D app.
So with that, you
now kind of have
an idea of what are you
building-- an app that's
meant entirely to be a
Daydream app from the ground
up, which we think is going to
be the vast majority of stuff,
or are you going to introduce
a Daydream experience
to your existing app?
And so you're ready.
With these choices, you're ready
to submit your app for review.
And so I'm going to invite
Alex, who is going to tell us
about what happens after that.
ALEX RUSSELL: Thanks, Brahim.
BRAHIM ELBOUCHIKHI: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
ALEX RUSSELL: All right, so
you've declared the intent.
You want to be in the
Home Launcher environment.
So, as Brahim was saying,
you declare the intent.
And when you do this,
this will trigger a review
to make sure that it's
actually a VR app.
This is similar to
Android Wear, where
they check to make sure
things are actually
watch apps, or Android
TV, where they're
looking for actual TV apps.
So because we care
about you understanding
exactly what that
review involves,
I'll tell you specifically.
There's 13 criteria
that we're looking for.
And if we add
additional things, we'll
be communicating
that out as well.
Obviously, we care a
lot about transparency.
We want everyone to
know what's going on
with the review process.
And it's all pretty
straightforward stuff.
So let's start off
with the basics.
And with basics, we just
have one through four.
This one doesn't really count.
This is more this
kind of baseline.
Your app needs to
actually install and run
so that the reviewer can use it.
Although, surprisingly,
sometimes that's not the case.
Assuming that works out, moving
on to the actual review--
performance.
So does the app
maintain 60 frames
per second over
long play sessions
on a Daydream-ready phone?
We'll be following up with more
details about exactly which
phone models we'll be testing on
and how you can replicate these
tests on your side.
So there shouldn't
be any question
about if the test
was run correctly.
But this is really important.
It's important
for users enjoying
VR and the success of
the overall platform
and the quality of experience we
want to have in the ecosystem.
Number two, as Brahim was
saying, never go to 2D.
This is kind of a tautology.
It's like a VR app stays in VR.
But it's really important
not to accidentally throw up
a dialog box or something
in 2D when the user has
their phone in their headset.
It's a really bad experience.
In particular, if you ask for
particular permissions, things
like camera or contacts,
those will actually
currently trigger a 2D dialog
box in VR, which is not good.
So we'll be looking
for things like that.
And if you do need to ask
for those permissions,
just doing it in a 2D
flow before the user gets
to being in VR.
And you'll know
when you're in VR,
so then you know not
to call the permission.
Number three-- this one's
pretty direct-- App stays
in landscape mode.
Obviously, if the user moves
their head to the side,
you don't want the
phone reoriented.
Number four, also, you'd
think it's very direct,
but a lot of apps are
currently doing this wrong.
Use immersive fullscreen mode.
You don't want to have the
status bar and system bar
on screen when the users in VR.
Some people will accidentally
go into lights-out mode,
where it dims them.
You can still kind of see them
in your peripheral vision,
and depending on the lenses,
you might really see it.
So you want to use, obviously,
the entire screen to show
your VR content.
So that gets us through
the super basic stuff.
Moving on to comfort--
items 5 through 10.
Number five, users
can focus on elements.
So in VR, you're showing stuff
stereoscopically with lenses.
If you bring objects
in less than a meter,
but especially like
getting in that kind
of 10-centimeter
range, a lot of users
aren't going be able to
focus on them, especially
if this is like a critical
piece of interface
or your menu or
something like that.
If the reviewer sees
that they're actually
having to go somewhat cross-eyed
and they can't actually
focus on objects, that could
trigger this being an issue.
So, as a general rule,
for really critical stuff,
you want to keep
it more than half
a meter away from the user.
And in your own
testing, you're going
to realize this
because you'll have
trouble using your own app.
Number six, app
maintains head tracking.
So similar to
performance, you really
never want to freeze
the camera in VR.
As a user's moving
their head around,
you have to always update.
But something that we
found is a lot of apps,
they'll have great performance.
But then when they're
loading a new scene,
the app will freeze
for maybe half a second
or a second as that
new scene loads in.
And it's not because the
app had bad performance.
It's just they
actually were done.
Now they had to
load the new scene,
so they didn't
have an opportunity
to maintain head tracking.
So those things can still make
people really not feel good,
like even just a second here
and there can be a problem.
So if you're going to
have to load a new scene
and you're not doing
asynchronous loading
or something, just fade to black
or fade to any solid color,
so the user doesn't have objects
onscreen that they can realize
the head tracking turned off.
If you actually want
to play with this,
in the Cardboard design
lab, we have a demo where
tracking turns off randomly.
It doesn't feel great, if
you want to experience it.
Also on the topic of not
feeling great, stable horizon
line-- if the app has
a visible horizon,
it needs to remain stable.
A quick example of
this-- I apologize.
Let's keep it on screen
for a little bit longer.
And then you don't want
to drop frames like that
either-- also not good.
Yes, so this is a big thing
for user comfort as well.
Then number eight, users
initiate movement--
so if users are
moving around a scene,
you want them to actually
point and click to teleport,
or use the trackpad on the
controller to walk forward.
Even if it's a roller
coaster or the entire point
as they're getting in this
car and then the car is going
to take them around,
they should click
to start the roller coaster.
So at no point
should you just be
kind of randomly
grabbing the user
and flinging them
around to various parts
of your application without
them indicating that's actually
what they wanted.
They shouldn't be
surprised by that,
because it's part of the
surprise that actually affects
your level of comfort.
It's sort of similar to driving
a car, you don't get car sick.
But when you're a
passenger in a car, you do.
Because when you're
driving, you can anticipate
how the car's going to feel.
Another other example
of teleportation,
or any of these other
different types of locomotion,
we have that in last
year's Cardboard design lab
as well, where the user's
clicking to move about.
Number nine, honestly
represent content in the app.
Descriptions and
screenshots should
be generally representative
of what your app's about.
So imagine you have this
great meditation app,
and it's about hanging
out on the beach.
and the user's very relaxed,
and the palm trees are swaying.
And then 15 minutes
in or so, a zombie
shows up wielding a chainsaw.
That's fine.
But you should somehow indicate
in the description or title
or screenshots that that
was going to happen.
We don't want just
blatant surprises and kind
of trolling like that.
So that covers comfort.
Now on to Daydream integration
for the final three.
Number 10, app uses the
Daydream controller.
So the Daydream controller
comes with every single viewer.
Also, the Daydream
controller's required
to use the home screen.
So when the user
launches your app,
we know that they're holding
that controller in their hand.
We want all of the
apps on Daydream
to take advantage
of the controller.
In particular, if
you're bringing an app
over from Cardboard, just using
the controller as a clicker
doesn't actually count as taking
advantage of the controller.
We want the
controller to be used
for targeting input and
not the user's head,
since we now have an additional
[INAUDIBLE] controller.
Number 11, app has a VR icon.
So users are going
to be launching
your app from inside
of VR, so obviously you
need to provide this.
There's two aspects.
There's a background element
and a foreground element.
The reviewers are just
going to be looking
for little simple things,
like you actually filled
out the full texture.
So if you only paint
the front, and the sides
and back are white, that
might trigger something.
Also, it kind of sort
of shimmers in VR
if you didn't paint
the whole thing,
but pretty straightforward.
And we'll publish all
the specs for this.
And then you have a
360-photosphere screenshot.
We'll be using these in
a few different places.
One is in Play VR-- Play Store
VR-- as the user looks around.
As they're browsing apps,
this will be the environments
that your app is in.
And then, also, in
2D, we may use these
as like a Magic Window, where
you can kind of move your phone
around and see the app.
And then generating
a 360 environment
is actually really simple.
Depending on what
game engine you use,
you find the correct plugin.
In this case, it's
showing Unity--
so bringing in a
plugin, where you
can do a capture of panorama.
You're just attaching that
script onto a game object.
Then you launch the game.
In this case, you just
hit a key on the keyboard
and it generates the
photosphere for you.
So you can sort of stage
your shots that way.
And these plugins are available
across all the game engines,
and we'll be posting
links to them as well.
So that's how you get
listed in Play VR.
But that leaves sort of the
broader and more interesting
question of what should
you actually make?
To which, to some
extent, our answer
is like, well, it's
up to you guys.
You can be imaginative,
and that's what's exciting.
But there are a few things that
we're really excited about,
so we wanted to sort
of share some of that.
This isn't based on
really firm data yet,
because it's so early for VR.
A lot of this is kind of a
mixture of our experiences
and intuition and
observing other things that
are happening with apps.
So this is going to
evolve a little bit.
It's a little bit mushier
than, say, the 13 criteria.
But the first thing that
we're thinking about
is overall, what
experience do you want
users to have with your app?
We're finding this
is like an early way
that apps seem to be
bucketing themselves
into different categories in VR.
Do you want the
app to be relaxing,
or do you want it
to be thrilling?
And it's not the
case that one of them
is necessarily better
than the other.
They're just very different.
So roller coaster
apps are actually
very popular on Google Play
right now for Cardboard.
But just like how roller
coasters in the real world
aren't for everyone,
virtual roller coasters
aren't for everyone.
They have their market,
and other people
aren't super interested
in roller coasters.
So something we've
been thinking about
is trying to have a
little bit more structure
to this notion of what the
physiological experience
of the app is.
So we're referring to
this is motion intensity.
And currently we're bucketing
into three categories.
This might evolve
a bit over time.
We think that three is
probably useful to think about
as you're thinking
about the motion
intensity of your
application-- so no motion,
moderate, and intense.
And to help me explain
this, I actually
have a prop, because
sometimes this is complicated.
So here, this is the user.
It is also the camera
in your game engine,
and it's really
important to-- honestly,
I think the game
engines should actually
make them look like heads,
so that people remember
that this is the user
in their game engine,
and not just a camera.
Or as our filmmaker
Jessica likes to say,
the cameras are
made out of people.
So these can consciously
choose to look around
in any action they want.
But then, as a
developer, you can also
choose to move these around.
So, Brahim, heads up.
BRAHIM ELBOUCHIKHI:
You want it back?
ALEX RUSSELL: Yeah, sure.
Toss that out there.
Yeah, so, as a developer,
you want to be careful.
That's OK.
I've got another one.
The podium is actually
full of heads right now.
It's very weird.
So thinking about
motion intensity,
no motion is just the user
is moving their head around.
The developer's
not doing anything.
So things like watching
a movie, those types
of apps where you're still.
In terms of moderate
motion, the user
is moving in two
degrees virtually.
So they can move
their head themselves,
but say they're in
a car or they've
indicated they want
to walk, they're not
walking in real life.
But they're using the
controller to walk.
So virtually just kind of
traveling in one plane, that's
moderate.
Limited acceleration
and deceleration--
If you accelerate
really, really fast, that
would make it more intense.
Also, if there's a lot of
objects coming at them,
that could make
it more intense--
the combination of
the things coming
at you with you moving forward.
And then final category
for intense, this
is where you get into the
virtual flying and driving
and roller coasters
and spaceships
and that kind of stuff,
where in addition to the user
moving their head around, the
developer is also putting them
in a space ship,
where it is causing
three to six degrees of motion.
So we're still sort of figuring
out the details on this.
I don't actually need
the head anymore.
One way to think
about it is it's
the difference between
sitting, walking, and flying.
It's a little bit more
complicated than that.
Things like if there's
no floor present,
even if the user's
not moving, that
could be slightly disorienting.
So not having a
floor could cause
it to go between no
motion to moderate.
Or even if they're still and
there's very large objects
coming at them, that
can give the perception
that you're moving forward,
because you sort of lose
your grounding.
So that could also cause it
to go from no to moderate.
So we'll be publishing
more details about this
as we think more about how apps
would fall into these buckets.
We think it's important to have
the sort of physiological way
for users to think
about categories,
because some people are really
interested in some categories,
and other people are
interested in others.
So that's one way of thinking
about how to group apps.
But what about the genres?
What are the different
types of VR apps,
more in terms of content?
And that's sort of interesting.
It's like the genres are still
largely being discovered in VR.
We seem to see a few things.
In particular, games
and entertainment
seems to be really big.
But something we're
finding is this
is a general-purpose
computing platform.
This is Android.
So games and
entertainment are great.
But also VR can
be about much more
than games and entertainment.
And we're in the
very, very early days
of starting to see that emerge.
So here's some quick
ideas of things
that we're excited about.
Education is really interesting.
Google's done a lot of work with
expeditions and primary school.
But even education for higher
education is super interesting.
Learning physics in
VR could be great.
Learning organic chemistry in
VR could be really interesting.
Being able to engage the
user's spatial memory
could actually have impact
on their ability to learn,
and there might be some
real advantages to having
a 3D environment for education.
Architecture is something
that often comes up
and we're very excited
about-- not just
in the professional
use case, but also
users being able to model
things and play around.
Music is just starting to
emerge as a category for VR.
I don't know how many
people played Audio Shields.
It's really neat.
Also Daydream Labs has some very
cool experiments with music.
A lot of these, they're still
a little bit more traditional.
But imagine like
you're a DJ in VR
and you're going beyond
the physical constraints
of a turntable.
That could be really neat.
You can really play with
the concept of music.
You can even have the user
dancing, like the music
responding to them dance.
So I think this
sort of brings us
to the topic of like
going beyond reality.
A lot of VR apps
right now are awfully
grounded in reality,
which is weird,
because you don't have to be.
So there's lots
of things that you
could do that just simply can't
happen in the real life-- so
data visualization,
of course; being
able to understand
complex data, which
we haven't been
able to do before,
unless you build lots
of models about it.
Meditation could be
really interesting.
Music visualizations,
and kind of almost
synesthetic experience-- playing
with these types of things
could be very neat.
Also e-sports might
be really interesting.
A crowd forming to
watch other people
to compete at something
that goes beyond reality
could be a really
compelling use of VR.
So that's just some
of the initial ideas
off the top of our head of what
we think we might see emerge.
But what's exciting is
it seems like every day
we're seeing almost entirely
new app categories come out.
And there's lots of room for
exploration and innovation,
and really, you have an
infinite canvas to explore.
So with that, thank you.